COLLECTING THIS DATA.
IT HASN'T BEEN PUT IN A JOURNAL
YET.
THE FDA HAS TO WEIGH IN ON THIS.
IT'S BEEN PUT FORWARD FOR
ACCELERATED APPROVAL.
IT COULD BE A BIG DEAL IF IT ALL
HOLDS, BRIANNA.
>> I KNOW WE NEED DATA BUT LET'S
HOPE THIS IS SOMETHING TO BE
EXCITED ABOUT.
THANK YOU FOR WALKING US THROUGH
IT.
>>> MORE ON OUR BREAKING NEWS.
NATO THIS MORNING CALLING THOSE
MYSTERIOUS LEAKS IN THE
NORDSTREAM PIPE LINES SABOTAGE.
THE GAS PIPE LINES, THERE'S TWO
OF THEM, THEY RUN FROM RUSSIA TO
EUROPE.
THIS COMES AT A TIPPING POINT
TIME FOR VLADIMIR PUTIN'S WAR IN
UKRAINE.
OVERNIGHT THE UKRAINIANS TOUTING
SHAM VOTING IN ORGANIZED AREAS
OF UKRAINE.
THE BOGUS RESULTS SHOWING A
MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WANTING TO
JOIN RUSSIA.
THIS SIGNALS A VERY DESPERATE
PUTIN.
>> THESE ACTIONS FROM PRESIDENT
PRUT CONTINUE SIGNAL VERY
CLEARLY THAT HE KNOWS HE IS
LOSING.
HE'S ON HIS BACK HEELS AND HE'S
MAKING EVERY ATTEMPT TO
INTIMIDATE THOSE WHO WOULD STAND
UP TO HIM.
I WANT TO BRING IN JOHN BRENNAN.
MY FIGHT AGAINST AMERICA'S
ENEMIES AT HOME AND ABROAD WHICH
IS NOW ON SALE IN PAPER BACK.
I DO WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT WHAT
THIS MAY MEAN.
THE SHAM VOTING RESULTS AT A
TIME WHERE YOU HAVE FORMER
PRESIDENT MEDVEDEV WHO'S A
FORMER RUSSIAN OFFICIAL SAYING
YESTERDAY, RUSSIA -- WE'VE HEARD
THIS BEFORE, HE'S MAKING THIS
POINT THAT RUSSIA COULD USE
NUCLEAR WEAPONS IF ITS EXISTENCE
IS THREATENED.
NOW YOU HAVE THE VOTES OF PEOPLE
SAYING THIS SHOULD BASICALLY BE
RUSSIAN TERRITORY.
DO YOU SEE ANY THE SHAM VOTES.
>> I THINK THEY'RE SEARCHING FOR
THINGS TO DO AND TO SAY THAT
WILL INDICATE TO THEIR PEOPLE AS
WELL AS OTHERS THAT THEY ARE NOT
LOSING THIS WAR AS BADLY AS THEY
ARE.
POINTED OUT, THIS IS A SHAM
ELECTION.
IT'S ILLEGITIMATE, ILLEGAL TO
HOLD SUCH AN ELECTION IN A
FOREIGN COUNTRY.
MEDVEDEV HAS NO IDEA IN TERMS OF
WHAT NATO MIGHT DO AND RESPOND
IN TERMS OF WHAT RUSSIA MIGHT
OPT TO DO ON THE NUCLEAR FRONT.
IT'S CLEAR THAT RUSSIA IS IN A
DOWNWARD SPIRAL.
THERE IS DOMESTIC OPPOSITION TO
THIS PARTIAL MOBILIZATION.
I THINK THEY ARE GOING TO SEE
ADDITIONAL SABER-RATTLING.
AND CONSOLIDATE THEIR WHOLE ON
UKRAINE.
>> YOU'RE SEEING THIS MASS
EXODUS OF FIGHTING AGE MEN FROM
RUSSIA AS PUTIN IS DRAFTING
THEM.
YOU'VE SEEN SOME ATTACKS AT
RECRUITING AREAS.
WE'RE EVEN HEARING INTERSECTS OF
GRUMBLINGS FROM TOP MILITARY
OFFICIALS.
AT WHAT POINT IS THIS GOING FROM
GRUMBLINGS TO DESTABILIZATION
FROM PUTIN TO RUSSIA IN YOUR
OPINION?
>> I THINK WE'RE SEEING EARLY
SIGNS OF WHAT IS SERIOUS
POLITICAL OPPOSITION TO PUTIN'S
WAR IN UKRAINE.
AS THESE YOUNG RUSSIAN MEN ARE
TRYING TO FLEE THE COUNTRY.
IT'S LEER THAT A LARGE PORTION
WILL BE SLAUGHTERED.
THEY'VE DONE EXCEEDINGLY WELL TO
WITH STARNTD THE RUSSIAN
ONSLAUGHT.
THE NUMBER OF RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
KILLED IN THE TENS OF THOUSANDS
IS CLEARLY SENDING A CHILL
INSIDE OF RUSSIA RIGHT NOW.
I THINK WE'RE GOING TO SEE MORE
OF THIS.
THE QUESTION IS WHAT WILL BE THE
BREAKING POINT AND WHAT CAN
PUTIN DO TO TRY TO REVERSE IS
CLEARLY A VERY BAD TRAJECTORY
FOR HIM.
>> DO YOU THINK HE'S STABLE?
DO YOU THINK HE'S WELL?
>> I THINK HE IS WHO IS FEELING
INCREASINGLY SET.
HE'S ISOLATED.
HE IS ALSO TRYING TO HOLD ON TO
POWER SO I THINK WE'RE SEEING
INCREASINGLY DESPERATE STEPS
THAT ARE BEING TAKEN AND IF
THESE EXPLOSIONS IN THE GAS --
EMBASSY GAS PIPE LINES OFF THE
DANISH COAST ARE ACTS OF
SABOTAGE, I THINK WE'RE GOING TO
SEE MORE AND MORE THINGS THAT
PUTIN IS GOING TO TRY TO DO TO
WEAKEN THE RESOLVE OF THE NATO
COUNTRIES.
BUT ALSO TO TRY TO INTIMIDATE
ANYBODY WHO MIGHT OPPOSE IT.
>> DO YOU THINK RUSSIA IS BEHIND
THE SABOTAGE OF THE PIPE LINES?
I THINK ALL THESE PIPE LINES ARE
IN 200 FEET OF WATER.
RUSSIA DOES HAVE AN UNDERSEA
CAPABILITY TO LAY EXPLOSIVE
DEVICES BY THE PIPELINES.
I THINK IT'S A SIGNAL TO OUR LOP
THAT -- THIS IS CLEARLY AN ACTS
OF SABOTAGE.
>> WHY BLOW UP THEIR OWN
PIPELINE IF THEY CAN CUT OFF THE
GAS?
>> THERE'S NO GAS FLOWING.
THAT'S WHY METHANE RELEASED.
IT WON'T TAKE MUCH IF RUSSIA
DECIDES TO GO AFTER THE OTHER
PIPE LINES THAT ARE BRINGING GAS
INTO EUROPE.
I THINK THIS MIGHT B